The joe rogan experience.
I do bad shows.
If I'm hung over,
I don't like my shows.
They don't feel good.
They don't have the flow to them,
you know?
And I,
I just,
I hate that feeling.
I hate the feeling of being on stage and it's,
it would be my fault if I was hung over if I was hung over on seats.
It's like,
it's my fault that I'm working at like three quarter speed right now or it's not
clicking right now.
Like that's so,
yeah.
Well,
I wish I could just have one,
but it's not satisfying because you have one and then you want a hundred and,
and then,
and then you drink a hundred and then you feel like shit.
And like if I just drink one,
like I've have one at lunch,
then it's like I want to go take a nap.
If I either got to keep going,
if I keep going,
I can go for like,
you know,
a good hardcore for,
or a gentleman six
and then I'm done.
But like,
uh,
I,
yeah,
I feel pulled to it.
No.
Is it like Gollum in the ring?
No,
I just,
I don't know what that means.
I just like,
no,
no.
I don't even know what that is.
I don't want to see the Lord of the rings.
You didn't see the Lord of the rings.
I went to one of those and it was so fucking long and every time they wouldn't,
they would fade to black.
I'd be like,
just roll the credits,
roll the credits,
and then they would open up on some big field and it's just like Jesus,
get the fucking thing back to the guy so we can get out of here.
I hate,
I,
you know what?
I fucking hate all of them and I fucking paid,
people don't have a sense of humor about the bullshit that they watched when
they were kids.
Like adults who talk about star wars,
like that isn't a fucking movie now when you watch it,
I mean like how busy,
terrible.
I was making fun of the other night.
The other night I came home,
I got,
I got free,
uh,
free Cinemax,
which is the greatest fucking channel ever.
They either 24 hours a day.
They're either showing the greatest movie ever or the worst fucking movie ever.
And it's all compelling as I watch like nine movies in a row,
like this fucking channels.
Unbelievable.
So I ended up flipping up,
uh,
cause late at night.
They just had some sort of,
you know,
softcore porn,
which is ridiculous now when you have the Internet.
So just was redundant.
Sorry,
I got off of that.
So I went on to VH one.
Uh,
and,
and they were playing this show metal mania and I was watching all these bands
in these videos that I just thought were fucking sick and they were injured.
The devil,
Dude,
I was just by the NFL.
It's like,
how is this better than disco?
Like why did disco gets so much shit?
Like I'm not talking about like the iron maidens and metallic Metallica's,
but you know what I'm talking about?
That middle of the fucking ground,
those people with the spiked fucking gloves and all this stupid shit and rom
meat and it was just,
it was horse shit.
It was fucking,
I watched it.
It was the dumbest shit ever.
It was embarrassing that I,
I mean,
I moved,
granted I had all of that music still on my iPod.
I'm not,
I'm not above it.
But if someone were,
were from this generation would have come back and tell me that music was awful
and it was stupid.
I would laugh.
There's like,
there's no way I could defend it.
Isn't it weird how you look at,
like if you look at music or you look at movies,
that's like one of the clearest examples of like some sort of a evolution or
progress is going on with humans because like the,
the movies of the past,
like so many of them are there are so clunky and the,
the,
the style of communicating is so artificial.
It looks,
it's,
it's such a shit,
you know,
representation of life
in comparison to a real good mood until the 60 once they figured out,
you know,
like,
just acting on film,
like those people just learning how to do it.
So everything was,
was,
uh,
gonna be not like that type of acting had to go away with the Brando's and the
James Deans.
And those guys.
And then you had to have like the uh,
there's a couple of wood,
like this movie's back there like Jack Lemmon,
the apartment.
Well the hustler is way ahead of his time that the hustler,
Stanley Cooper,
Cooper,
that type of shit.
There was some guilt with it still holds up though.
But those were the bad movies from the 60s and the 70s you know,
watch like try to wash like Jaws Three d
oh yeah,
no,
this,
is this a bad bill always had,
they still have movies like sure.
I mean I think the shore to this day transformer shit,
even though I didn't see it,
but if you see it and I never,
I never vibe with Scifi people,
like Scifi listeners,
I always get trashed by them because I just don't,
I just don't get,
unless you don't get Psi Phi at all.
No.
If it's like aliens,
like it has to be high quality.
Like aliens is like the Goodfellas of that side.
I like on like top shelf Skyfii I'm going to be in the blade runner,
the aliens and that type of Shit.
But if I'm just going to go watch,
you know,
oh we're,
we're in hoth.
I even,
what the fuck that's from?
What is Hoff?
Is that,
that's a star wars thing.
I don't know.
I don't know what that is.
Like one of those fucking things,
the action figures and shit and it's just you like transformers.
I didn't like,
I didn't like Chewbacca Chewbacca.
It's like,
dude,
you're a fucking fucking awesome guy to have around.
He's huge.
And imagine you can party with bigfoot.
I would totally party should be ripping somebody arms off.
He's shooting a gun.
Like he's a fucking,
he's like,
he's,
he's a bad ass limit is how to shoot guns too.
He'll rip your fucking arms off,
but he can also shoot you from a distance.
Bitch.
He's limited.
Oh,
I like to box.
I would totally hang out with,
you know what did that and again,
you know,
I didn't like about him.
He was a follower.
Well started.
He started hanging out with all the humans and next thing he knows he's sitting
up right.
And chairs,
right?
Sip and little juicy juices.
Yeah.
I wonder if he can understand it.
Could they understand him?
They could speak to that.
I think it was a language,
but we just didn't understand it.
So all that same fucking thing.
Not that many wookies you know,
it's like Chewbacca and like there's no other
what he was like the Dodo bird.
No,
weird.
We're going to be destroyed on Twitter cause we are star wars knowledge and you
know,
we're going to get this shit forever.
There's a fucking million wookey's.
There is a nation of Lucky's.
There is a federation of Little Keys,
you know,
not what you're talking about is nothing better than just having a fucking 10%
knowledge of the sizing of it because it's just driving some kid nuts.
Okay.